my mission is to improve lives so I want
to do things that put positivity and
positive energy and love into the world
you're gonna turn your scars and make it
something positive you know you got to
create the kind of energy that you want
in your life if you constantly keep
creating positive energy around you then
more positive things will come rise and
shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message put positive
energy into the world over you Will
Smith so for me a personal confrontation
with death made me see the value of time
and the fact that the only elixir is
love you know so the the time that you
spend has got to be in preparing
yourself and giving and receiving the
most amount of love you can my mission
is to improve lives so I want to do
things that put positivity and positive
energy and love into the world I think
the best entrepreneurs are mission
driven you have a mission you want to
accomplish something you want to change
the way something that's done in the
world you're not here just to try to
make money and then make a buck and sell
products and services but you want to
fundamentally change the way something
is done those are the people who have
the big impact who changed the world
right entrepreneur we want to do that
where is the source this is always
fascinated me and I believe that the
source often comes from a big place of
pain as much as we want to lean in on
the optimism it comes from pain and so
if you look at Will Smith he has the
near-death experience leads to him
valuing time wants to make time
important wants to put positive energy
into the world right comes from the
paint come to the near-death experience
I look at myself my one word is belief I
believe in people why do I pick
entrepreneurs
where does the source come from i could
say i entreprise are gonna solve all the
world's major problems I fundamentally
believe that I think entrepreneurs will
solve all the problems of the world we
don't need to rely on the governments
and corporations and wait for the
president or prime minister to solve
something we do it we see problems we
fix it and that's motivating that's
inspiring
but the real source of belief for me the
real source of the mission comes from my
pain in starting up as an entrepreneur
comes from me feeling really low on my
life the worst days of my life were in
my first business I felt worthless I was
making 300 bucks a month eaten beans
every day for lunch just feeling like I
was trying everything that I could to
make my business work and nothing was
working out and I still remember the
pain of showing up every day going to my
business partners apartment working from
his dining room table because there was
no space in his office and just
struggling and our only wins would be
going to McDonald's and getting french
fries he couldn't afford the entire meal
if we got a client that would be our
mini celebration and I remembered not
being able to go out with my friends
because I didn't have the budget I
didn't have any money to spend I
couldn't go to birthday parties or pizza
or beer or anything and I was too
embarrassed to tell people that I was
really struggling financially I just a
member how hard that was and how much of
a personal burden I faced and how I
almost quit on my business partner and I
told them that I quit and so I needed
more belief back then I needed somebody
to help me believe more in myself and my
real passion is in helping others
hopefully not face the same burden and
problems and pain that I faced and Will
Smith too wants you to live your life
and put positive energy out into the
world without having to go through a
near-death experience so that's where
the passion comes from that's where the
mission comes from a deep source of pain
and trauma in your life that then you
want to make it easier for other people
to win believe is my core value my one
word but I love helping entrepreneurs
because I just want to make it easy for
entrepreneurs I know how hard it is I've
been there and I don't want you to have
to feel the same thing I felt the
feeling of
worth a lack of it feeling worthless on
a daily basis I look at Alex who's one
word is belong he helps me run trying to
dance salsa along comes out of a big
pain point for him he had a condition
called hyperhidrosis where he would
sweat a lot and so he could never dance
because his palms always sweated like
crazy and he felt like he never belonged
because he wasn't accepted into the
group now eventually you know he had an
operation he fixed it and why dancing
well because he he wasn't able to dance
and why belong well because he never
felt like he belong and so that insane
pain for him of not being able to touch
her girl's hands and dance with her and
feel like he was never part of the
in-group
now he wants to make it easier for other
people because he understands the worst
of the worst he never wants anybody to
have to go through that and so he's
trying to be a beacon of light in the
other way and so having those traumatic
experiences those massive points of pain
does one of two things it either
keeps you in the pain and you become
resentful and angry and nobody can
succeed around you when you took your
shot and you had this pain and so life
sucks and everything around you sucks
and you become this toxic virus that
spreads to everybody who you infect with
the conversation or you go the other way
and you say that really sucked
I wanted to never happen again in my
life and I want to make it easy for
other people around me I want to be the
beacon of light against that toxicity
and I think that's what entrepreneurs
really do best and I think if you have
an important mission you have to find
the source of the pain because that
gives you the motivation to keep going a
lot of times to me the motivation to
keep going make videos see you a
conferences meet fans here at the studio
comes from me knowing that some of these
people were just like me you're
struggling you have an idea you're
putting everything got into it and it's
just not working out and nobody believes
in you I want to be that guy I want to
be the guy that I wish I had and I want
to try to hit as many people as I can
because if I can hit a billion people in
a half-percent way to just be a little
bit of spark a little bit of believe
magic you still have to go and do the
work you're still 99.5 percent of
everything else but if I agree that half
a percent
and spark a little tiny change for a lot
of you that's all you need and so if you
are struggling if you are down if you're
trying to figure out like what do I stay
in for how do I tap back into what this
is all about I would encourage you to
look at what is the pain that you went
through that you're trying to make it
easier for you to never go through again
and then for your kids your community
the people around you ultimately maybe
the world to never have to face you're
gonna turn your scars and make it
something positive now have a really
special bonus clip for you but before
getting to that I want to know question
the day what is your pain what is your
scar what is the thing that really drove
you that you never want to have happen
again for yourself or anybody else in
your aura in your area anybody who you
touch what is that thing leave in the
comments below really curious to find
out thank you guys so much for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso and enjoy the bonus clip
so my father was a was in the
construction so I used to like help him
out you know
as far as building houses and stuff like
that but I didn't really start working
until I got out of jail for the first
time when I got out of jail for the
first time I did a yeah in jail for son
Brad he would intent to kill the only
reason I did it if my father was trying
to teach me a lesson because I was such
a bad kid so he was trying to teach me a
lesson so instead of posting my bail he
let me sit in jail and I'm like I don't
know 16 17 in the top playing 97 96 97
yeah so I didn't when I got out of jails
when I started saying yo in order to
change my life I got to change my
lifestyle so I didn't want to hustle no
more and I never was no big-time drug
dealer I was 1/4 spoon to you know
quarter spoons when I'm from his 7 grams
he paid to 54 G flippered you make fire
on it but when I went out the first jobs
I started working I remember I got a job
at this warehouse called IAC
dust real acoustics company I worked
there and I worked at on a flower garden
and I worked at Taco Bell I worked at
demo in the mall I worked at a
telemarketing place called Paragon
solutions and the reason I was doing all
that could always say you know you got
to create the kind of energy that you
want in your life if you constantly keep
creating positive energy around you and
more positive things will come so I
would be landing all these jobs like I
never was one that left my record to
stop me my criminal record and that's
what eventually led me to get an
internship with directors because I was
just working I was working two and three
jobs at one time you know at one point I
worked at demoing the mall
Paragon solutions to telemarketing
agency and and interned at the radio
station
it's not like it's like a psychic
telling you yo you won't be rich one day
so you just sit around and wait to be
rich and I don't work like that you know
when you're constantly thinking about
doing positive things you got to
actually go out there you work towards
those goals I thought I told you earlier
about just going out and working at Taco
Bell you know working at a warehouse
just trying to create that positive
energy of production into my life I as
you know I was a bouncer for many years
I remember coming home one night after a
big fight
run up to the kitchen and I get ice and
I'm my hands swollen and then just
another day at work and I was feeling
like just bummed about the fact that I
was still doing this job after all this
time and I'm at that one moment I was
like why aren't people what what what's
up why do people have so much anger why
do I have to you know why is this my
daily life to suppress everybody's anger
or check everybody's anger that comes
into the giant 3,000 person nightclub
mm-hmm and my father it was so simple
but my father said you know then I've
traveled around the world I've been to
India I've been to Russia I've been to
China I've been all up in the Southland
all through South America and I've
realized something I said what he said
people by and large are good people
sounded pretty simple and yet it meant
so much and if you look at my facebook
page if you look at the way that all
that positive energy I don't think
there's a page in the world in history
that harbors as much positive energy as
one would see on this Facebook page and
it's when you put out to and it's really
that right and I say that because I say
that because if you believe that in your
heart and not everybody watching this
can say that or is ready to say that or
it's comfortable with themselves enough
to say that but if you really believe in
your heart that people by and large are
good people it affects the way that you
address the world as you see post in and
post out I address a world that in my
soul I feel is comprised of good people
[Music]
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
up or so it would be like a little
beacon hey believe nation if you want to
know what the most important one word is
for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details